Martin welcome to Microsoft research
it's a real pleasure to be hosting you
today as part of the MS Rai
distinguished lecture series and we've
known each other for probably 20 years
or so now and I've always valued you as
a colleague in information retrieval you
have a really broad perspective on
helping people articulate their
information needs find relevant
information and so on
25,000 citations you receive just a
couple of years ago I believe the Tony
Kent Strix award in for lifetime
achievement in information retrieval and
actually maybe a more broad award the
same year for induction into the Royal
Netherlands Academy of Arts and Sciences
and although speak to your amazing
research career and and impact one of
the things that I want to do is start
will talk certainly about some of that
but I want to start back up you know a
little bit before you got into
information retrieval so your bachelor's
degree was in mathematics and philosophy
what what what was what led to that
combination of interests
thanks sue it's great to be here and so
when I finished high school I was
actually quite sure what I wanted to do
so I had jobs for a few years and then I
became more and more interested in
information how can language convey
information how can I share information
with you how can language express
information about the world and then
okay that's an interesting topic and so
I went to study philosophy what was the
angle just this sort of knowledge
knowledge representation no just
philosophy philosophy
the concept of information the concept
of language conveying information and
being used as a mechanism for people to
exchange information and so then after
already after a year I discovered I need
math to be able to do this more deeply
and gain a better understanding so I
then I picked up mathematics as well and
then first you do a bachelor's and then
you do a master's and so you took that
that path
one of the things like I noticed in in
doing a little bit of background
research on this is I've known you for
many years and is an information
retrieval person but you spent the first
ten years of your career looking at
formal logical methods knowledge
representation and things like that
you have several papers in that area
that are cited thousands of times I
think the book that you co-authored with
Johann van Bentham's is that right well
with two other students of his and Edith
ænima yeah okay great was cited 4,000
times or something on that order tell me
about that that career and then also
what led you to think about a very very
different perspective on problems - all
right yeah and so picking up on
information yeah the topic that we just
mentioned so there's a natural for me
there was a natural connection to to
nords representation to thinking about
formalisms to capture the information -
and then to prove theorems about how
much they could capture the power prove
theorems about how expensive
computationally it would be to reason
with them that an led to the book
because the results that we discovered
back then weren't in any of the standard
text books on logic and we felt we had
we were on a mission the world needed to
know about this so not what did you do
you write a book well let me get picked
up yep I did and and after a while I
wanted to not just prove theorems but
also use these results in some sort of
application and where I was back then
there were connections between knowledge
representation and more formal ways of
reasoning with databases on the on the
one hand and with natural language
semantics on the other and because we're
worse back then the Institute and the
neighboring Institute's there were quite
a few people working on knowledge
representation formal reasoning and
databases so I thought well there's no
space for me there I'll take the other
and so that's when I got into question
answering writing and look at question
answering as an inference problem
represent the question in some sort of
formal language represent Canada dances
in some sort of formal language and then
proving that something is an answer to a
question you do some type of inference
and okay this sounds easy do you then we
need to find those documents potentially
contain an answer to begin with and
they've turned about turn out to be a
lot harder than and I had in visits and
that's how I got sucked into it so
dealing was really the ambiguity of
language sort of the fundamental
ambiguity of it and then thinking about
formal structures that you might need on
top of that so one of the early things I
remember that you did besides the
question answering work because I was
working in some statistical models of
question answering around the same time
but I remember your work on XML
retrieval yeah and that's is that an
example of trying to mixed some formal
notions of knowledge representation or
maybe more structural and freeform kind
of characteristics yeah exactly exactly
because the idea was these XML
annotations certainly the ones that that
are semantically a bit more meaningful
than just document structure the idea
was this would help us to pinpoint
better answers and even at a document
structure level maybe I can say if
you're doing retrieval XML retrieval on
scientific documents and you have a
section that's marked up with a results
section or conclusion section and you
you find a hit in one of those sections
maybe that's a better hit and hit that's
in the related work section so it's a
way of embellishing that kind of
completely unstructured retrieval models
that had often been in favor certainly
30 40 50 years ago and I think we're on
a journey think to this day of thinking
how to blend the right mix of
kind of freeform pretext information
with more structured information and so
what what techniques did you use at that
time to address that did you treat it as
kind of fielded retrieval or were you
able to leverage and in other ways
various attributes of that structure
you look for evil sort of almost SQL
like okay first find elements of the
right type and then rank them by by
analyzing their content or the other way
around also try to learn or estimate
somehow the degree to which the user who
formulated the original query would find
it important for that item to be for
that element to be exactly the element
that they asked for
whether a neighboring element would also
be fine so what if someone asked for
abstracts that are about a topic and we
gave them introductions that were about
a topic would that be good or bad and it
turns out you infer those really those
relationships the substitutability or
near substitutability was it question
analysis content analysis some
combination of those question analysis
indeed and and so back then this is
tracked like event called INEX that set
up that set up quite a few of those
benchmarking activities and with
different formats one format would be
sort of content and structure queries
about certain elements of a certain type
about a certain topic and other other
setups were you just get a a content
query and you need to infer what
appropriate structural elements would go
with that topic and it turned out that
when you asked users even if they said
they wanted abstract about a topic there
would be could be perfectly happy with
conclusions about the same topic so the
structural concerns weren't actually
very hard constraints or they were maybe
more salmon
syntactic so they wanted a high-level
overview perhaps not so much an intro or
a conclusion or yeah they just didn't
want to be in the weeds indeed yeah
those are really interesting reflections
I wouldn't switch gears a little bit to
a couple of other efforts that you've
done over the years
one was I you were really an early
person I think in that Trek community
looking at search over social media and
in particular blog search and that that
turned out to have very some really
interesting attributes in the in the
sense that it was a mixture of content
as well as ways of expressing yeah that
content can it can you talk about some
of the challenges that you got excited
about in in those cases or the advances
in new techniques to address some of the
challenges yeah so what's what's
interesting there is that you you you
had to deal not just with usual
ambiguities that you have when you work
with language but also the creativity
and enormous creativity which people
would it could be creativity in terms of
spelling it could be frankly unusual
ways of referring to a topic with words
that typically weren't used for that
topic it could also be mixtures of
languages the Dutch and English for
instance or interesting punctuation and
so rather than thinking of this as they
suggested noisy language no this is this
is language and how it evolves and how
we need yeah and and so the challenge
that was always to recognize that for
what it is but make make stuff findable
nevertheless so that certainly was the
the big challenge another big challenge
was finding good Assessors for this for
retrieved results so certainly in the
early days the Assessors were track
Assessors these are not typical blog or
Twitter users and so there was some of
the early assessments I don't think
we're very meaningful
this is not a complaint about the
assessor's it's just a myth it's a
mismatch between the the information
needs and and understanding what would
make for relevant sources of information
and the background of you know of the
people who are helping us make that
judgment
and so at a in some later work we we
worked a lot with people who do social
media analysis for living so they in a
communication agency tracking say the
reputation of a brand or of a company
and try to learn from them what are
influential posts what are post that may
have a strong opinion but are not gonna
make a difference anyway so you should
not rank them at the top so discovering
that so these are posts that we are very
relevant but for a variety of other
reasons in terms of the the influencer
the person who wrote it the redundancy
they're not gonna be with ya or maybe
they were posted you know days after
when when the topic first hit the
Twitter feeds you know there are no
longer they were no longer relevant so
understanding this mixture of content
Authority quality timeliness
I think these first of all understanding
that these were factors that play a role
in addition to things like credibility
right it was a really exciting time
because what's the IR work before that
had been done with well curated sources
like news stories or abstracts and you
mentioned just a whole bunch of
dimensions that that people really
needed to address it's certainly work
that's relevant to web content although
increasingly much of that is pretty well
curated rather than then I don't know
maybe more informal more genuine and
inside just a different perspective on
the way that people can communicate
their lessons from that that are
relevant now is is we think about social
media and how it's evolved over the last
decade think about things like deep
fakes of various kinds are there
interesting lessons because it seems
like a lot of the attributes that go
beyond
are equally relevant to some of those
areas certainly there's a lesson from a
retrieval point of view one important
lesson I think is who is the user that
were modeling who's the user for which
we're retrieving or finding information
and what should be conveyed to that user
and we return the results so for
instance further for the social media
analysis tour the reputation manager
that I just talked about we had to
indicate temporal factors influence
structure around the original poster
what have you and what do you mean the
person who posted a message how many
followers does this person have the
organization for which he or she works
how how many followers are there etc how
frequently does this person post and so
that's the whole influencer structure
right the same individual for a normal
layperson who uses social media some of
these factors play a role as well too to
give that person a scent of the
credibility of the information the value
of the information that the degree to
which it should be trusted but those
people maybe should also see other
aspects such as well there are other
forms of view on the topic this is maybe
it should flag that something is a
controversial topic or or you should
fact that we have trusted sources from
which this comes or we don't have them
so that you inform users of aspects that
they may want to take into account when
making a decision whether to believe
something or not whether to act on
something or not and so I think that's
an interesting additional aspect to all
of this how do you make this information
actionable for the reputation manager
actionability meant this is going to be
picked up
at large-scale we need to do something
for a normal lay person maybe
actionability means gift upper equipped
that person so that they can make an
informed decision and that may mean show
other perspectives quality indicators
credibility indicators I guess that one
of the and that's changed I think a lot
in in the last four or five years as the
minute there's money to be made if we're
generating content that captures
people's attention and may in be from a
very particular perspective there there
will clearly be a lot of opportunity to
try to get people to believe that it is
more or maybe authoritative or more
broadly believe than it is and so it's
actually interesting to think about
reflecting some of the attributes that
underlie both the creator of the
information the Pat their pattern of
interaction and do you see any of that
in in current news sites or social media
sites and I know you're not working so
much in this area anymore so it's a bit
so with some of the news platforms or
news aggregators they try to indicate
some of them may try to indicate some of
these these factors some of these
aspects they certainly indicate time
time but it's interesting it's time
since they often times since the article
was created not time since you you might
have viewed it or you know okay thanks
that was really an interesting set of
reflections on the blog work the the
last technical area that I guess I want
to focus on is the work that you talked
about today during your lecture it was a
really interesting and broad perspective
on conversational systems I think you
know more and more with the advent of
mobile devices where people are speaking
rather than typing
you see people talking and in more
natural language to information systems
can you talk a little bit about the
journey of your lab and looking at some
of those those questions right so the my
lab focuses on information retrieval so
connecting people to information and the
implications of the the technology that
we helped to develop there originally we
set out as a normal search engine lab
right in comes a query return ranked
list of documents and then of course
you've realized that in many cases
people may have any funny information
need but may not actually be expressing
it all you know is it's that person
again you have a profile and so then you
do to slowly drift into recommender
systems rather than search engines in
the conversational systems are sort of a
mixture of these two because as someone
might ask for might ask a question you
may be able to respond but often this
the question is ill posed the the
underlying need is not actually
expressed very well so you may you may
actually have to generate elicitation
questions or preference questions in in
the case of a recommender systems system
and then the next step after that is now
what if we did a way altogether with the
situation where someone has a gigantic
screen there's no screen there's no
keyboard there is some sort of
interaction there is some sort of
conveying of information and expressing
of information needs implicitly or
explicitly and so that's how we slowly
by asking these questions how we slowly
drifted into conversations we're
certainly not done there's an incredible
amount of work to be done there and
what's interesting is as I try to
illustrate in the talk today is that
we keep going back and forth between
search recommendation conversation and I
think the conversations generates new
interesting new search questions
interesting new recommender questions in
terms of even the notion of conversation
and yeah yeah there's many ways to view
conversation right one of them is just
maintaining state of some sort you've
alluded to a couple of others of helping
people really going back to some of Nick
Balkans early ideas on helping people
identify an anomalous state of knowledge
and to to help people articulate what
they're what they're actually looking
for and so that that's a very
interesting aspect of some of the
conversational applications that that
you're working on in my mind yeah I
think so too and these there's so many
factors that play a role there and of
course as a researcher you you you don't
want to affect all of these factors in
one go you have to do a proper
experiment you you yeah we've you
fiddled with one factor and leave the
rest as much as possible untouched but I
mean you can think of different
scenarios where you know you might have
a conversation not with a large
collection of documents from which an
answer has to be somehow extracted but
conversation with with a single document
you know and then not just the content
but also the history of the document the
provenance the metadata you might have a
conversation with the collection of
objects and then this the conversational
assistant cannot just enumerate all of
the objects if someone has to what what
yeah what have you got show me some
interesting objects no needs to build up
a mental it needs to build up a model of
the user a mental model of that user
what does the person know what
we tell the person before how long ago
was that
she'll be refreshed that she can we
build on it and if we're not sure along
the way I just how do you have a
dialogue as you were at the beginning of
your talk Hugh
highlighted a number of things that
these kinds of systems would enable like
a conversation with a document or a
conversation with a structured database
and what are the interesting things that
got me thinking about is right now
most people's familiarity with
information search systems is web search
yeah and there we've almost been first
of all it's startling that you can issue
a query like Microsoft and find anything
that's really relevant amongst the
billions of uncreated pages so it's an
amazing accomplishment at one level but
it's also one that's stifling in some
ways in terms of the expressivity of
what we can ask about how there can be a
communication back and forth
communication to help people identify
things and the web has settled on a
scenario that is really ideal for a
large screen where you just put a lot of
information there may be different types
of information watch how people navigate
through that and one of the things I
really liked is in in the work that you
talked about is the opportunity to think
about a richer set of ways in which we
could seek information about individual
objects about collections of objects and
get much more than here's a web link
that to me is exciting it's also
incredibly challenging it's daunting and
so the one thing that's great about the
way that we now get SERP search engine
result pages is diverse it's rich it
offers tons of starting points for a
four-hour exploration but also
potentially very direct answers if the
system thinks that that's the best the
best thing it can offer to you and
what you can think of conversations as
okay narrowing that that enormous
bandwidth down to just one thread and
maybe that's the wrong way to think
about it but because all the richness
over sudden goes away when you think of
it that way right still you want to
convey that richness you want to convey
that maybe around the topic of Microsoft
there are tons and tons of potential
results to put different reading
different usages how do we convey that
can you talk a little bit about some of
the progress along that direction that
you shared with us earlier today and
then maybe some open research areas sure
so one there there's a bunch of
challenges here one is how do we make a
converse of a conservation sufficiently
rich engaging informative and many of
the of the models that we use nowadays
based on language models they tend to be
fairly conservative meaning that they
tend to repeat similar results to what
they've shown before and that's that
conservatism we're just a weird language
model that that you develop because of
base rates I guess it's maybe a
distinction about information versus a
converse a dialogue and a conversational
pragmatics that these systems have is
but I'm wondering whether it's in the
model the underlying model or in the
generation good question I tend to think
that it's of course it's a it's a it's a
matter of the data that we used to train
the model on but it's also a matter of
the generation model that we wouldn't
then fire and that tends to ring to be a
very local model that each time takes
the next most likely word or an axe most
likely phrase and that tends to be
fairly conservative and so how do you
make that richer how do you make that
more diverse several approach not
embarrassing
yes not embarrassing and not
inappropriate right that's that's that's
an interesting balancing act to perform
several things have been tried different
estimation methods different ways of
building the model to begin with
bringing in new sources of information
while you're doing the generation maybe
some sort of knowledge graph in the back
or or in some of the work that I
mentioned so-called background
conversations you're giving additional
documents that you can use to to inform
the device that generates utterances and
make it more specific make it more on
target in if there aren't so there's
tremendous possibilities in this area
and it's an area that were you know just
getting started in are there particular
scenarios or applications where you
think this will be particularly
illuminated illuminating is it
summarization of things that are going
on is it
really providing people with a way to
focus and pop and learn about new things
so I'm particularly interested in the
and provide more focus so what if you so
think about people who are have to
achieve a complex task and there may be
quite a bit of pressure guide them
through that the complex material that
may actually be arriving in real time
guide them through this I've helped them
through this the system will often tell
them what I should know but occasionally
the the user will interrupt and ask for
something specific and so these are
these could be this could be an in a
medical setting could be in a security
setting or even in a in a sort of
experimental lab setting where someone
is running a bunch of experiments so
thanks I think this for me this just
provided a you know a way of kind of
popping out of the web bubble and in
thinking about the kinds of information
and recommendation scenarios we can have
moving forward and even thinking about a
dialogue with your your document or a
new screen as a stream is really an
exciting month so I think it's a fun
area with maybe next time we meet we can
talk about some of the you know the
outcomes of that research and and we
could you could generate a whole new
craze and in in from just again thinking
about what's possible you know for
people I think that's a really exciting
aspect of this I would shift gears a
little bit and talk about you know
various aspects of your career and maybe
recommendations or or to for you know
students or people just getting into
this so one of the things that I think
of when I think of your many
contributions it's not just the the
great research work but the service that
you do to the the community in a number
of ways I think we first met when you
were not first met we interacted I think
pretty substantially when you were
running Cir in Amsterdam
you've also been the general chair and
co-chair of world wide web CI km ICT I
are just a lot of conferences you're the
editor-in-chief of a CMS flagship
journal and information retrieval how do
you balance the you know the time that
you devote to research versus these
these broader ways of engaging with in
communicating and shaping the the
community because it's a tremendous time
time and energy sink and and you it's
not like you did it once you said been
there and done that but you continue to
do it and help shape you know the work
and I should have mentioned in the
course of things it's not just
conferences its involvement in these
workshops clay and INEX and Trek how do
you think about the different kinds of
things you can accomplish in those
different ways of engaging yeah so in
many cases this is about spending energy
to get more energy out of it and so
certainly when you you help to run
say a track a track or a clay or a Dynex
you know you you try to energize
your colleagues and and together with
this group of colleagues you come you
you stumble upon new questions you
stumble upon different methodologies for
doing evaluation and so this going
through this shared research experience
with a large group of people outside
your own lab to me that's very
energizing yes that costs energy but
sort of speed that what you learn is is
in this is much greater than if you had
all of that if you had done all of that
by yourself with their own students in
your own lab and and so yeah I've done
that a few times for this reason okay
build a community around the community
there's some new work and interact I
guess in conversational you know I think
there as you mentioned there are huge
challenges in datasets evaluation and
and but this is the way that the
community can address that I guess is
yeah and and and you know if someone
else picks up on a topic and there's
already enough energy well great but if
I think there's some energy some topic
deserves more energy I'll try to push
for it through a workshop through a
benchmarking activity yeah
and that's it's also good for the team
right because you get your students and
colleagues together and you set this
goal somewhere in the future you run for
it yeah that's maybe one or two or three
years and then you let go but that kind
of work has been amazingly influential
and some of your early work on
question-answering was like that you
were involved in in video search for a
number of years again pushing directions
and so I think it's it's an interesting
way that people can shape the research
agenda the questions that are asked and
I think it's one that the people
especially students as they're starting
out need to appreciate as an amazing
contribution to the community not it's
not just a paper and no and but also for
students I think it's a it's a even if
for our starting students it's a great
way of becoming a mass
in your own area by creating that area
helping create an area yourself and I
often encourage to students to be on the
lookout for new tracks that are being
launched at track or at Mt cir or or at
clay because those those early stages
are where you can make a difference and
you can be influential they also set the
research agenda
anyway the community for better and for
worse I mean I think there are lots of
benchmarks everybody tries to get to the
top of the leaderboard but we do work as
a community where the light is or where
the data is and so I think it's
important to have a direction and an
understanding of where some of the the
big opportunities are in to try to
adjust those so thank you for all the
work that you've done in that that space
over the years you've had a number of
students your lab right now is pretty
large probably dozens of students we've
had the pleasure of interacting with
many of them through internships through
several of them our employees now I
think of people like Katia Hoffman or
and and others one of the things that
that is true and I mentioned this
earlier today when I introduce you is
that your students seem to have this
interesting mix of really great
foundational work but also interest in
taking making those ideas real and I
think it's part of the culture and in
your lab to work with real people and
real problems so can you talk a little
bit about how you pull that off how you
work with government agencies local
nonprofits commercial companies yeah so
I think it's it's good to do great
science but it's better to great science
with great impact and so I encourage
students to to do the great science but
also do this with an outward focus so
try to get problems from outside outside
academia try to get data from outside
academia try to seek opportunities for
evaluation outside where someone else
gives you the yardstick or the
measurement device and not you as a
student and this is interesting
Santo metric work that shows that first
this was only published after I've been
doing this for a few years after the
facts that shows that if you look at
publications and their impact in terms
of citation analysis and the different
author teams involved with these
publications then you know you can see a
gradual increase in impact if you go
from single author publications to multi
author but from the same Institute multi
author from across Institute multi
office international multi author
academic industrial or academic
governmental it just goes up and this
has been repeated across many
disciplines across many universities so
and I think that's also where we should
be as me as an academic researcher and
not doing academic research for its own
sake but contribute knowledge contribute
knowledge that makes a difference I
think it does things other than that's
clearly scientists we all hope that if
we solve a hard problem somebody will
care and this is a way of doing that it
it's almost reminiscent of past Donald
Stokes's book on scientific research and
talking about Pasteur's quadrant here
because a lot of that was foundational
research that you hope is generalizable
but motivated by real world problems and
it's very interesting to see you know a
lab that that has historically that that
focus so some of that may just be your
preferences in in research style but
it's it's clearly prevalent and you know
and the students who've who've come
through you know your lab and in the
breadth of your publication yeah and so
what would have been spending quite a
bit of time on the last two years is set
up an Innovation Center for ya that is
founded on this principle so it tries to
team up universities with companies or
governmental agencies shared research
agenda the students in those labs spend
one or two days a week at the sponsors
Institute and the original ambition was
to open I think for labs of this type
per year we're now at in nearly two
years in at close to 15 labs when you
say a lab you mean a collaboration
between opportunities at least five PZ
students okay for a five-year period
yeah I think you know the beauty of that
is that it also one of the interesting
things when you have test collections
for example is the metrics are defined
that datasets defined and what you work
on are the algorithms or little bits and
pieces and it's you know somebody who
spent a you know career in an industrial
research I think one of the the bigger
challenges you need to learn and it
sounds like you know your lab is focused
on this and your students are focused on
it is understanding when you have a
problem how you develop the right
metrics how you develop the right set of
algorithms the right end-to-end solution
and so I think it's a really exciting
thing to see coming out of you know at
university thanks do you have any advice
in closing to students who are thinking
about getting into the you know the
space at the intersection will say of
information access machine learning
artificial and intelligence what what do
you look for in you know it's selecting
students to to work with you or what
yeah what advice would you give to
incoming
be creative that's number one be
creative and be opinionated and open at
the same time so that's a difficult
combination but you need to develop your
own ideas while developing them you need
to find a good balance between being
stubborn and being open to to criticism
and then execute and so this is
interesting mixture of stubbornness and
an openness that's hard to develop right
and hard to know when to close off for
the rest of the world and when to open
the windows and so that's something I
try to foster in my students both the
creativity try new things be really
critical about where the added value is
and in terms of what's a new
contribution in right be critical be
more critical than your reviewers in
moderation if you're overly
self-critical nothing gets done nothing
gets done the at the end of the day it's
yeah this sounds old-fashioned and I'm
boring but it is you know pick up stuff
that you believe in and run with it it
doesn't really matter what it is just
you know you believe in it you believe
that it's scientifically important it's
something that will make a difference
somewhere on the planet run with it
well that that problem choice that
passion and so on or as you say really
important and so I think it's it's great
advice to to students as they're they're
starting out of thinking about research
careers to develop that point of view
and then pursue it with there may be a
you know a focus but also be open to
I think so and I see that in your work
over and over again and in many of the
students who come through your lab so
thank you for being here - you know
today to talk with us but more
importantly for the ongoing
contributions of you and your students
to the information retrieval and
recommendation community more broadly
it's been a pleasure thanks
you